velas y flores acompañan las preguntas
de estos migrantes y activistas reunidos
frente a la estación migratoria de
Ciudad Juárez
decenas llegaron para rendir homenaje a
los muertos en el incendio del centro de
detención mientras otros buscan
respuestas sobre el paradero de sus
familiares
me doy cuenta que todo tan quemado
no dan razón cita en un hospital está
vivo está muerto y todos los que estamos
aquí nos sentimos también con el mismo
dolor la misma preocupación y asustado a
la vez porque si pasó esto ahora que más
adelante va a pasar un miedo compartido
al sur del país por los migrantes que
acaban de entrar a México por la
frontera con Guatemala muchos llegan de
Centroamérica y como los que fallecieron
en Ciudad Juárez quieren terminar su
viaje en Estados Unidos
pensaron que yo iba en estas personas
pero gracias a mi Señor Jesús acá estoy
estoy viva Y
ahí sí que lamentamos lo que pasó con
estas personas
la tragedia se produce cuando Estados
Unidos y México están lidiando con un
número récord de cruces en su frontera
compartida y mientras la administración
biden ha estado utilizando una ley de La
era de la pandemia para devolver
migrantes a la frontera según la
organización internacional para las
migraciones desde 2014 más de 7.600
migrantes han muerto o desaparecido en
su viaje hacia Estados Unidos